just keep that in mind if you do have
any questions you can post them in the
chat box as we are getting started
and we will take some time after
everybody completes their presentation
to have a discussion
about any questions that are raised
during this session
okay welcome everyone to this free
webinar
uh this free webinar is going to be
dedicated to
our omixlogic research program that is
focused on infectious diseases and we
will have several people present
as they speak about the application of
genomics to
structures of proteins and how that can
be
a way to investigate drug resistance
vaccine design
and protein protein interactions based
on structural
computational biology so thank you for
joining us today again
bibsa who is normally taking these
sessions and
doing the presentation slides is not
going to be
available to share the screen so i'm
going to do it instead of her so if
things don't
go as smoothly as you would expect that
is why
okay so uh let me briefly introduce you
first to our armix logic programs
uh this presentation or the free webinar
is a part of the collaboration with
a group of uh researchers out of naguchi
memorial institute for medical research
at university of ghana there they are
interested
in analysis of genomic
transcriptomic and structural data
related to
infectious diseases specifically in
malaria and soros growth too
and so as a part of what we do here at
pine biotech
we run these onyx logic training
programs and a lot of them are focused
on these types of research questions
but to give you a broader perspective we
have been doing uh
omics logic for about a couple years now
and we've been successfully able to run
programs at several different
institutions including
louisiana state university georgetown
university amity university in
india and many others and as a result
we've developed collaborations around
the world
with researchers that are interested in
the application of bioinformatics to a
variety of different challenges related
to
biomedical research as well as practical
clinical applications of those research
findings
and other areas like biotechnology and
agrobiology
so our major collaborator in this effort
is the talber bioinformatics research
center which
is a research center that is focused on
development of
novel algorithms to address very various
research
challenges including the integration of
multi-omics data
now onyx logic was built as a
bioinformatics
training program that leverages some of
these
tools and research projects
to train people around the world
to have uh better skills and
access to big data processing
capabilities
on top of this research platform uh
called the t
bio platform so the omix logic training
program
has now over 10 000 users 30
universities and five local chapters as
you can see
around the globe so we're very excited
about growing this program and so we are
inviting most of you
uh that are joining us for the first
time to explore some of these research
pro
programs and that you can learn more
about
on the website learn.omixlogic.com so
you could please post that link in the
chat box
so as i mentioned this program is a part
of this
training program on bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
where we explore relevant tools methods
and data repositories
on a variety of different pathogens
including source cove2 tuberculosis
ebola and malaria we learn
from curated case studies and
peer-reviewed publications
and test understanding by analyzing
sample data
mastering key elements of analysis and
visualization tools
to be able to design and develop an
independent research project so
what are some of the things that we just
finished covering in this program that
is coming to an
end we talked about the applications of
genomic
transcriptomic and structural biology
data and then we focused more on
genomics so how can we actually use
variant
detection and variability
to start thinking about protein protein
interaction
as well as drug repurposing
and docking and so what we will do today
is we will focus on first of all how
genomic data can help us understand
infectious disease
progression and spread then we will talk
about
how this type of genomic information is
useful
for protein analysis and then we will
actually discuss
how this could be further
expanded upon using tools from
computational biology
based on structural analysis in
application to
drug resistance and drug repurposing in
malaria infection
so i want to briefly mention that the
program
is also coordinated together with
principal investigators dr anita ganza
who is a senior research fellow and
lecturer
at the nabuchi memorial institute for
medical research at university of ghana
and dr bright adu who is also a senior
research fellow and lecturer
there and uh to speak a little bit
more about how genomic data is
uh useful for understanding drug
resistance vaccine design
and protein protein interaction i want
to pass this on
to dr harpreet kahr dr harpreet kahr
is a researcher at pine biotech
but she earned her phd in bioinformatics
and her focus was on cancer genomics
but now she's expanding that to also
teach and talk about the applications of
genomics and transcriptomics and
infectious diseases and she is the
project mentor for onyx logic research
projects so harpreet i will pass this on
to you
thank you ilya for introduction
so let me share my screen
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur i have a phd in bioinformatics
in my current role i am omix logic uh
project manager and trainer with the
pine biotech
i am assisting participants to learn
about data analysis
machine learning and visualize
visualization
in application to the last data set used
in the biomedical research
today i am going to provide you a
glimpse how
uh should be the approach and where
genomic studies
can be applied using bioinformatics to
facilitate in determining the key
mutation
or and variance that can impact the
structure
and functional aspect of our protein
so in the year 2017 fang uh
lu at all published a research article
in the general parasite and the bacter
entitled returns of chloroquine
chloroquinol sensitivity to africa
surveillance of african plasmodium
falciparum chloroquine resistance
through malaria imported to the china
so the chloroquine is a drug that was
considered as
a cornerstone of the anti-malaria
treatment on africa for almost 50 years
drug resistance reports compel its
widely withdrawal
in this study authors monitor
chloroquinol
sensitivity and determining the
prevalence of genetic polymorphism
and chloroquine resistant transporter
gene that is crt
uh particularly this uh parasite that is
plasmodium falciparum
isolate recently imported from the
africa
to the china so based on the study the
authors suggested that
a reduction in the drug pressure
following the withdrawal of the
chloroquine
as a first line drug may leads to a
resurgence
in chloroquine and resistant uh
sensitive parasites
and uh eventually they conclude the
prevalence of bile
type of uh pf pfcrt chloroquine
sensitive parasites from the east south
and north africa was higher than
from the west and central area but
this varied greatly between different
countries
so now question arises how we
we can study key players that are
responsible for
drug registers what are and how we can
determine what are important mutation in
a specific protein or gene that results
in drug riches
resistance so once you have
like your ngs sequencing data and the
metadata regarding
which sample are drug resistant or which
one are susceptible
one can perform mutability data analysis
based on the per nucleotide mutations
which calculate
the mutation frequency so here we have a
simple pipeline by which you can perform
mutability analysis
so the mutability consider both mutation
frequency
with the coverage on our t14 server
one can easily perform mutability
analysis using simple
click on options next
based on the mutability result
one can perform principal component
analysis
to visualize the patterns of the samples
based on the mutability results
and we can find out which groups can
show clear deflection
among themselves we can also find out
what are different outliers like here
this sample based on the pca we can find
out what an important outlier
like shown in this orange color so one
can filter out those
outliers based on the pca
so once we got clear description uh
group based on the these pca results
like here we can see
this green group and this so it could be
uh
we can these groups can be from
different reasons or a different country
so for instance you want to find out
what a significant differential mutation
between the different population
from these two different reasons so one
can perform differential
mutation analysis again using the
different pipeline
uh on a t-band which is integrated on
our tabanfo server
so here one can find out what are
important mutations
like here you have a reference position
then based on which
whether a nucleotide is mutated to any
alternative allele or if there is any
uh deletion or an insertion one can
analyze those results
so another way to find out the key
mutation between different sample
is multiple sequence alignment and we
can
also perform phylogenetic and analysis
on the tbi4 server
we can perform multiple sequence
alignment
uh based on cluster w algorithm using
this sigma info
server and here we can perform multiple
sequence alignment with both
if you have faster data in the faster
format and the fastq format
so from the msa analysis we will get
important information like here we have
this table
that can be used to identify important
variants or the key mutations
between different samples so for example
here let me
show you uh here based on the msa we can
find out what are important mutations
that are taking place at nucleotide
labels among our different samples or of
among different populations
so then we can also find out what are
important mutations which are actually
translated at amino acid label
so subsequently we can find out what are
important variants
among these samples so this is we can do
with both in our and uh on using the
server that are available
on our two different platforms
so then it is important to understand
whether mutations
those mutation that you have identified
are biologically significant
or not so many nucleotide substitution
have number of
effect on the phenotype even if the
chains occur in a gene that encodes a
protein because most amino acids are
specified by
more than one codon so the substitution
that does not change the encoded amino
acid is
known as synonymous substitution or
synonymous mutations
while non in case of the non-synonymous
mutations
when a chains at a codon labor also
result
at amino results in changing amino acids
those are called non-synonymous
mutations so
to understand the biological impact
we should proceed what are
non-synonymous mutations
so once we have already identified
non-synonymous mutations
next question arises where these
mutations
are located on a protein like whether
they are located on any functional
domain
or not so eventually if they are you
uh if they are located in a specific
position
on some functional domain then we can
see
and analyze how these mutation
eventually impact the protein structure
and functionality so to talk about
uh talk about more in this respect i
would like to pass this session to mr
nysel so over to you guys
so nisel is there
and angel can you hear us
right i can hear you now i was talking
about come on
yeah thank you very much let me share my
screen
over to you guys thank you
and rita um i'm sorry i can't i can't
seem to share my screen
could you please share for me i i don't
know what's happening
uh so nigel we can see your screen i
believe
okay just not the presentation
and well this is not my screen i think
this is a screen
okay yes
maybe you can re-share your screen
yeah so i don't know if she's going to
be sharing anything but maybe we should
try again nigel
right
okay
okay
hello
yeah i think i think we just need to
find another way nigel so if you can try
either sharing your screen or we can
maybe move on to mohit and then we can
try again if you want to try it
all right
i think i think you can move on to more
here because it's
i honestly don't know why i can't share
my screen
okay
let me share my screen then
sorry everyone about this just a moment
and we'll be back
okay so can you guys see my screen
yes we can
so hello everyone thank you for joining
today
and um as we are speaking about the
session and already being introduced by
ilya
so i would not take much time about the
session itself but to tell more
more about what we are going to do so um
we are going to talk about computational
biology first so computational biology
has made powerful advances so
amongst these trends in human health has
been uncovered through heterogeneous big
data integration
and disease associated genes were
identified and classified
so uh to everyone who's joining for the
first time my name is
mohit mazumdar i've completed my phd in
computational biology and have been
working with academia and
industry to solve important research
problems
so in my current role i'm working with
students
who have interest in doing research
in bioinformatics they're from high
school they're from undergraduations
colleges undergraduates and they are
also for researchers and phd scholars
who are working on buying their own
bioinformatics projects
are and are interested in completing
their projects
so uh in today's session uh talking
about structural computational biology
and the combination of structural and
functional study
i think the combination of both
structural and functional studies
is one of the most rewarding one of the
most rewarding route
to the understanding of this basic
molecular uh
basis of biological function so to
consider
uh the structural aspect and then
correlating it to the function
and then coming to the understanding so
the computational
so computational biology is essentially
what it does
is it integrates these variety of tools
and heterogeneous data into a this
comprehensive
spatial and temporal uh description of
biological process so it's very
fascinating
so in today's talk uh we will learn
about tools
and approaches that are used by data
scientists
and bioinformaticians and in
collaboration with experimental
biologists
to address some of the challenges that
we see in drug resistance especially
drug resistance in malaria
so as i was telling you that our talk
today would be focused on
a couple of uh major topics
and those major topics is that how we
can
uh use the data that is available
out there and make the most out of it
and understand
uh and connect the dots so
so it has been like almost i guess 20
years
since the first reference genome
assemblies were published for
uh this uh for plasmodium falciparum
so this deadliest malaria parasite and
this uh
anaphylaxis can be the most important
mosquito vector
of malaria especially in sub-saharan
africa so now i mean
there are so many reference genomes that
are that now exist
for all human parasites and there are
nearly uh
40 important vectors that are around the
world so
as a foundation for this genetic uh
genetic diversity
and to understand that genetic diversity
there have been there have been so many
studies
so i recently just looked into uh the
paper that came out
uh in malaria and uh i saw that
they represents now data from different
regions
and that's so amazing so these reference
genomes uh
have helped advance our understanding
of basic uh disease biology to now drug
and
insecticides resistance and different
types of resistance that we are seeing
and that is going to help us in taking
the right kind of decisions
in vaccine development efforts so that's
what we are trying to come up at
so our team recently published this blog
post that talks about system biology
and multi omics approach and pin points
to some of the publicly
available resources so
maybe i can share or maybe
anyone else can share this link so
you'll find it in the chat and if it is
not then i'll share it
later so talking about this entire
process
of uh thinking in the context of solving
a problem
by using multiple and heterogeneous data
sets and then
um then uh trying to figure out
strategies that could help us you know
uh come up with a solution uh to these
these
major problems so a system biology
approach so understanding the system
biology approach
approaches for promoting and developing
of these new therapeutic drugs
is now attaining a lot of importance uh
especially nowadays
so the study of interaction between the
components
of biological system and how these
interactions
give rise to function and behavior of
that system
is something that you can say is system
biology
so um today we are going to practice
some of it
and learn a lot about it so
one of the very important question and
and today we are going to talk about in
the context of
malaria research and the drug resistance
problem especially so that is the case
study that we are taking along with this
session
so this very important question of
developing
vaccines and drugs right and then
integrating a system biology approach
and learning what other researchers have
tried
and then connecting the data and filling
up the blanks
so today we are going to take you
through a small case study that we have
prepared as a part of
of uh our ongoing projects on malaria
and kovid19 as india told you in
collaboration with dr anita and dr
bright
from nmimr so
how do we start so to simply
say this and simply put this what we
have to do
is that we have to use the knowledge
about the parasite
uh the insect vector the human host
um and then um all of this is
again rapidly expanding this knowledge
about all of them and the challenge is
now to translate this knowledge
into tools that could be used to expand
uh that could be used to impact the
disease and its transmission
so based on all this information uh we
have to come up
with strategies and um that could be
used as a tool
for finding the solutions so
uh the problem at the same time is that
the
exploration of this fundamental systems
are generating new and interesting
basic biological questions every day so
we are getting this data being generated
and it's being published and being
deposited
uh so the human host and the insect
vector the parasites
they are also interacting in a complex
system ecology
so that interaction you have to take
into consideration as well
right so we we can see this evolution of
both parasites
and the mosquito vector occurring in
real time so this emergence of drug and
insecticide resistance are the prime
examples of that right
so how they are evolving so they are
evolving so we have to evolve our
strategies to be
able to counter that problem and for
that luckily we have now
so much of information out there which
we have to connect
and then we have to think that what can
be done so that's what
the session is going to all about is all
about and also the entire program and
the projects that we are doing
so in the context of structural biology
so structural biology if i tell you a
little bit in the depth so
structure structural biology is an
approach which is based on
free energy landscape that we are
looking at then we are looking at
population shifts
or the redistribution of confirmation of
substrate in an ensemble
so maybe these uh keywords might sound
heavy for you
but visualizing them and thinking in the
context of
like multiple structures is something uh
that you're analyzing a population
and then in a real time when uh when
uh when a structure is an emotion when
you are in motion
when the proteins are moving inside your
body so that's where
physics come in comes in and then when
then we are talking about conformational
substrate
in the ensemble so so it includes
linking and thinking about the basic
physiochemical principles that drives
the physiological functions
and dysfunctions in a disease so we have
to consider the basics
we have to consider uh the understanding
of what already have been
achieved so finding those drug target
correlation drug drug correlation and
all those correlation plays
important role even for drug repurposing
so
in in the context of structural biology
this conformational view
form the basis of many computational
structural
biology projects and that leads to
distinctiveness
and also innovative advances so
that's my take from this approach
and now uh i would want to talk a little
bit about
how to go about this so i have been
working with several of these projects
uh throughout my uh career throughout my
phd time and throughout
also now so i've gained some experience
working in this area
and you know seeing how problems come up
and
how uh to find maybe probable uh problem
strategies that can
solve those issues at hand so uh one of
the
basic uh pandas in here is uh to find
the right resources and much of our time
goes into that
and that is uh pretty important so how
do we how can we save
time and how can we reach to a
conclusion so starting a research
project
is i mean it's
still easy but completing a research
project
is kind of challenging but at the same
time
completing a research project is also uh
rewarding
right and there's a sense of achievement
that we get out of it
so finding the right resources uh from
the data itself
so in structural biology what in the
context of structural biology
when we are discussing finding data we
think about uh structural data
so we think about protein data bank so
many of you might have heard about
protein data bank many of you
have not so maybe if you have not
you can put that in the chat and maybe
we will go into protein data bank and
explore how
this uh big repository of structures
look like
so please put it there so if you want me
to go to protein data
bank please put one if if you don't want
me to go and if you know about it then
you can put two or nothing
so next is the secondary analysis
so once you have the structure then you
analyze the structure
then you understand and then you
annotate the structure
so we kind of talk a lot about a
sequence annotation
and there are several tools available
for sequence annotation
and as the structures structural data is
growing
uh i think a lot of importance is now
given to
these amino acid residues that play that
is playing it that is playing a critical
role
and that we got to understand from
genomics so
from genomics we got that special
residues those residues that are
important uh in the context of the study
and then we have to find them out
and understand what they mean and uh if
they
if they can tell us more about that what
is going on
and then uh the tertiary analysis and
this is like a circle
we have to learn and move on and then
understand
and then incorporate so it's like we
have to uh
improve keep on improving so those uh
those information are finding out in
from the databases
and then use tools and uh understand put
them into a report
so reviewing is a critical component of
this research
process so reviewing and being
not biased about your analysis or about
the thought
and start not start with a you know a
goal already like
the challenge sometimes what happens
especially in structural biology
especially in research is that
we have a predetermined goal so that's
what i'm coming at that uh those
biases should not be there and we should
see that data openly
so uh that was about problem or
question which is pretty pretty
important and then uh the solution or
the answer the solution
the solution or the answer lies in these
different steps
that we go through from uh from one from
another
in this entire process of the research
so uh the hypothesis
again the hypothesis uh building the
hypothesis is correlated to
all of our research that is going on in
related to the structural biology aspect
of
looking into the data so when we are
developing hypothesis by looking at the
mutations we are looking at
a different type of interactions that
are going on and based on those
interactions we are trying to
you know understand that how uh the
structural
changes have affected the function of
the protein so finding that
structure and function correlation and
then hypothesizing that okay this might
be the case
and then after you do the hypothesis
then you have to do the hypothesis
testing and that's where i think
molecular dynamics simulations and
docking
and those tools are helpful because that
helps us
understand or validate some of those
hypothesis that we have generated
and also going back to the experimental
phase
and doing those experiments to uh to pin
that to the uh to the places that you
have pinpoint
so before that when you are not using
big data when you are not doing
uh in-depth analysis you are coming to a
conclusion based on single uh single
gene analysis
now what you're doing is that you're
considering all of the components
and then developing an hypothesis and
then testing that hypothesis so that
kind
kind of validates a lot of this into
defining and you're
putting your hypothesis out there and
also to validate that
so in the context of today's problem uh
the anti-anti-malarial drug resistance
we will be talking in the context of how
we can annotate
a problem that uh that we have
maybe nigel would have if if nigel would
have started then
you would have known about the problem
but here i will let me define the
problem
so um the anti-anti-malarial drug
resistance
in plasmodium falciparum so as as you
know
there's a link that is out put here
that you can all go to and look in the
into the resources that are available
available at this website malaria gen
so from looking into the sequences and
understanding so here
you are seeing a sequence alignment of
uh another protein and a structure of
another protein
but to correlate about the understanding
of how these sequences affect the
residues and affect the affect the
behavior of the protein
make it drug resistance is something
really fascinating so how this is
happening
how these uh organisms are evolving
against the drugs and how we can counter
them is something that we are going to
do next
so in that context we would want to
first
understand what are the mutations that
are annotated that are
that we have looked into so in this case
study we started uh
looking into that so we kind of started
looking into some of the data sets
that are available some of the
literature that is uh
available so here uh
you will see uh
so here you will see about uh the
different drug resistance
uh mechanisms that are there
and also the proteins that are involved
in different
sort of uh resistance so
as you see that that this is not a
problem that could be defined from a
single protein perspective
so there are multiple proteins and
pathways that are involved to understand
the drug resistance problems
problem in malaria so here our focus is
crt so chloroquine resistance
transporter uh so today we are going to
talk about it
but before we talk about that let's try
to understand a little bit about the
mechanism
of resistance so the mechanism of
resistance can happen through
i mean maybe few ways so
one way is that the mutation in the
target gene
that is what we are looking at so we are
looking at finding those mutations that
enabled
that gene to skip
or to find a way and
get resistance so that is one
another is increase production of target
and then decrease
uh drug accumulation so that is in the
context of efflux
and then drug activation so
in the context of drug resistance uh
when we are talking about
uh the increased production of target so
this another mechanism
which is involved in drug resistance
that involves
expressing express expressing higher
levels of target so
this can be accomplished either
through increased transcription
and translation of gene amplification so
this results in a
in a requirement of higher level of
drugs to achieve the same level of
inhibition right
so this is one method another is
decreasing drug drug accumulation or
metabolizing
metabolizing the drug to a non-toxic
products that will result in less
drug reaching the target and also
contribute to drug
resistance so that's another mechanism
the another
mechanism that we discussed that we want
to discuss is that
drug resistance can also involve the
accumulation of mutations
that is in the same or different targets
which will have a addictive or
synergetic effects
so you can see it's quite complicated so
parasites with mutations or genetic
polymorphisms which confer
which confer a decrease in drug
sensitivity can
be selected uh under this drug can be
talked about in
under this drug pressure so
that is about the drug uh different type
of drug
resistance mechanism but here in today's
session
our focus is to learn about the drug
resistance that have developed through
these major mutations
and these mutations have been uh
these mutations have been uh
characterized by scientists
by uh involving doing these several
experiments and different groups and
then they get characterized and then
they get listed
so i do have a small
video to show to show all of you about
this chloroquine
quinine drug resistance
so maybe i'll try to play and you can
tell me if you can
listen to it or not if it is audible or
not
okay thank you
malaria is a disease which results from
infection
with plasmodium parasites
this parasite is dependent on the
hemoglobin
to obtain its basic nutritional needs
globin chains provide the essential
amino acids
but heme residues are toxic to the
parasite
this parasite protects itself from heme
toxicity
by polymerizing heme molecules into
hemozoin
anti-malarial drugs like chloroquine
bind him molecules and prevent their
polymerization
into hemozoin as a result of this
inhibition
heme will accumulate within the parasite
and the toxic effect will increase
eventually killing the parasite itself
thank you so
this was about the mechanism and
how this uh chloroquine works so it's
kind of
important to understand uh this before
going into the experiment and designing
experiments so that's why we showed you
this video
and further like structural annotation
so as i was telling you more about
that that it's important before going
into the docking or
simulations we have to figure out that
what is going on
uh with the protein and why there are so
many
uh drug resistance uh problem that we
are seeing
so there are studies that reflects
exactly that that how this
has happened and what is the reason so
pfcrt is
uh is the molecule that we are studying
so
so uh in the context of ph crt
there are post-translational
modifications that can happen
so those can be uh phosphorylation
phosphorylation
ubiquitination and all of that so
however the impact of these
post-translational modification on
plasmodium falciparum's
biology and in particular the drug
resistance
so that that is something that has been
kind of
addressed in this in a in using some
techniques
in this paper that came up uh quite
recently in 20 2019
so here they are confirming that
sorry so here they are confirming that
at uh serene 33
there is phosphorylation and also at
four one one position of this pfcrt gene
so this chloroquine resistance uh strain
um
of plasmodium falciparum so they
showed a kinase inhibitors uh that can
uh sensitize this drug responsiveness so
they use crispr cas9
genome editing uh technology to generate
a genetically engineered pfcrt variants
in the parasite
and then they showed that this uh
residue that uh serene 33.
we'll stop seeing your slide sorry
oh okay
sorry about that
okay so here i was so as i'm telling you
this publication
uh about pfcrt the talk that talks about
the post-translational modifications
and then looked into the residue such as
serene 33 at 33 position
so which was not characterized uh before
and then they they did uh crispr cas9
genome editing to generate those
variants
and then they showed that uh this uh
to when they change it to alanine uh
this mutation
then they found out that the chloroquine
and coenin
resistance was reduced to fifty percent
so uh as i was telling you that before
going into the structural analysis
if we can consider these mutations
positions and
look into the literature that actually
helps us a lot so
in that context we kind of started
looking into the different literature
that is available with this mutations
so this is open data set of plasmodium
falciparum
genome variation uh that user that uses
like 7000
worldwide samples and in this study what
they have put up
is that they have released data
that classifies these samples into
different types of drugs
drug resistance based on these published
genetic markers that includes snps uh
single nucleotide polymorphisms and snvs
copy number variations so the methods of
this classification is kind of quite
heuristic
and the one of the findings
in there is that you can look into the
uh different types of
uh drug resistance happened in different
proteins and what are the residues that
are
critically affected by that so here you
can see a list of
drugs that are being used in a
combination
as well as uh by single uh
single uh delivery so learning about the
pfcrt mechanism so before we go and
learn more about uh through structural
analysis
uh what we can learn through the uh
literature
from the literature review so uh uh
the spread of this cqr so we can say uh
chloroquine
resistance as i'm seeing it saying at it
as cqr
which is quite widely used so the spread
of cqr has led to successive
this anti-anti-malarial drug
replacements
right and then since 2020
uh sorry since 2000 uh they have
people have adopted to this uh
progressive way of arthemosin
based combinatorial combinations therapy
so
ac acts right so this
mutation in this plasmodium falciparum
uh
gene so chloroquin chloroquine uh
resistance transporter gene
it confers to resistance to several
antimalarial drugs so that is uh
kind of quite sure so that is
chloroquinoquine
or pipe uh piperacqua 9 so
piperaconine is another partner molecule
that is
uh being administrated with arthemacin
based uh combination therapies
combination therapies so this
entire uh this uh this transporter
so it's very important to learn about
the transporter type so
it's a membrane protein so as a member
of this
drug metabolite transporter so it's a
drug metabolic transport
porter super family so this vacuolar
transporter pfcrt that may translocate
substrate molecules right
across the membrane for the digestive
molecules like uh like
lysosome like organelle so uh this
physiological substrate that goes
that binds and like that that gets
transport
and that mechanism
and the mechanism
yeah so as i was telling you that
understand uh what we are trying to look
at here
in structure wise is that uh that we are
first of all looking at this uh
transporter and we are trying to find
what we are trying to understand is that
how this how it how it works
so what is the transport mechanism and
what are the functional regions
that uh that we cannot we that we can
characterize
and look into so this uh
anti-anti-malarial drugs such as uh
chloroquine or piper quinine
or uh amidoquinone or there are others
as well
are thought to be primarily interfere
with the conversion like you saw in the
video
so the conversion of toxic heme to a
non-toxic hemozoil crystal
so this process has been especially
characterized
for uh chloroquine which is uh like
found in uh high concentration and
leading to accumulation of this toxic
effie hemi
and then the death of parasites so
that's the mechanism that it used to
follow without resistance
so next
is to learn about the structure of pfcrt
so the main genetic determinant of this
uh
cqr in the plasmodium fencing param
claus
this gene that it encodes uh
424 amino acid protein for uh
24 amino acid residues uh
in the protein structure and it contains
uh
here one two one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
so ten transmission transmembrane
helices which are
essential for this parasite uh
intra-erythrocytic development
so at least uh the six independent
origins of these
uh mutations have been already reported
so there are different uh
mutations that have been reported in
this gene and
are quite prominent so
this various mutations in pfc crt
haplotypes
so we kind of discussed in genomics that
studying the haplotypes and different
sets of uh
non-synonymous mutations such as the
mutations that we see in asian
populations
and then that issue and that like that
that
later spread to the african population
where there's a high level of
transmission so the mutant pfcrt
molecules have acquired the
ability to expel uh the cq
out of the dv so all the cqr haplotypes
carry the
key k to uh k 76 to t mutation
so here in this cavity you see a red
zone out there so that's the mutation
uh that removes a positive charge in the
transmembrane
helix and then this uh
suggests because this is a change in the
charge this mutation
that suggests a charge dependent
transport mechanism
in this uh chloroquine which is
diprotonated in the
acidic environment so this k 7060
mutation is always
accomplished by additional mutations so
those
additional mutations may increase the
cqr level
or the fitness of fitness cost of
resistance so these are some of the
key uh take away from the structure that
uh structural analysis that a group did
so i'm going to present their work now
about the structure
structural analysis that they could come
up with and the models they could
propose
so another important aspect of molecular
dynamics
[Music]
molecular molecular docking and
molecular dynamic simulations
is the part where we do the molecular
modeling so it's very very important
and the reason it's important is because
uh the system that you're building
so the system has to be accurate enough
to mimic what you're trying to
you know uh see inside right so what we
are trying to do is
run simulations we are trying to run uh
uh trying to simulate a binding
uh binding process right when you're
trying to do docking you're trying to
simulate a binding process
and then uh when we are trying to do it
through similar
from molecular dynamic simulations then
we are looking at
what we are looking at is that how that
uh
binding effects or how the protein
functions mechanistically
and with a mutation so it's moving and
when it is moving
it is functional and then when it is
functional it should behave in a certain
way
so those are the patterns that we want
to see in the data
so coming back to the pfcrt structure
just a second
yeah so maybe i'll take a break and look
at the questions if there are any
questions so far
okay um i think you can continue i have
now the slides for rita and nigel so
after you finish
i will show their slides and hopefully
nigel can speak over that
so the next part would be i would want
to do
some structural uh classification and
then structural analysis so i think
maybe it would be best if uh
nigel can talk about the problem now and
then we can show
the practical outcome sure
okay you can hear us great okay so i'm
going to
uh show your slides and
if you can speak to
okay i'll share my screen
all right so you can
thank you very very much and sorry
everyone for the delay
previously things we can't really
explain
here but thank you so hello everyone my
name is
nigel dolin and i'm a research assistant
at
the niguchi memorial institute for
medical research in ghana
i belong to the bioinformatics
department where my research is purely
focused
on computational drug discovery for
neglected topical diseases like
bully or sign fiction infectious
diseases like malaria tea
i am entirely grateful for the team at
behind biotech
whose program and supports have been
very very invaluable
and we almost do with a genomics program
and the wealth of knowledge gained from
the program is not just meant to be
spoken of
but to be experienced as well right
the next slide so it is in light of this
that
and i together with my team including
retired jeans
and rp and dranita ganza i explained a
project in malaria another topic says
we are looking to elucidate genetic
diversity
in malaria drug resistance gene pfcrt
for its impact on drug deployment and to
model
efficacious drugs
now why malaria malaria is a protozoan
prostatic infection transmitted by
certain species of an offline mosquitoes
four species of plasmidium commonly
affect humans but one
which is the plasmaline phosphorum
account for the majority of the
instances of mobility
and mortality and that's reported by the
world health
organization an estimated number of 20
20
28 million cases and 405 000 deaths
in 2018 alone have been recorded and
children are children under the age of
five are the ones that are mostly
affected by
this by malaria and it would also
surprise you to know that ghana falls
among the
15 highest building malaria countries
yes and that's the country why i mean
the next life thank you and to
talk like he told the burden of malaria
there have been drugs that have
that have been used in example of which
is chloroquine
supadoxin parameter mean and and present
current or current frontline and
treatment which is that
listening combination therapy they are
the acts
but however recent mutations have
threatened and continue to threaten
their efficacy
and of much focus for us right now it's
um chloroquine
which this which will be the focus of
our of our discussion here
and clockwind which is there which is a
member of the four amino
was um the gold standard for the
treatment of
uncomplicated malaria for many years and
but is no longer appropriate for the
treatment of
plasmodium phosphor malaria in nearly
all areas because of drug resistance
which is a major major issue right now
next slide please
and so like i said before and actually
listening based convention certification
it's the current frontline and treatment
for malaria
and initially we've
we've noted or has been recorded that um
there's no treatment failure which has
been linked to
its cities in southeast asia countries
like thailand and
myanmar and then
just in our continent africa there have
been early indicators of
opportunity resistance even in rwanda
and so our focus of the web therefore is
to
is to constantly track resistance in the
transformational population
and so that we can also understand the
resistance mechanisms
and sort of suggest noble attacks that
could
hello and suggest noble drugs that could
circumvent the resistance of of a
malaria
caused by plasma phosphorus next slide
please
right um
two genes which have been implicated to
m cause resistance anatomy
resistance are the plasmodium phosphorum
and chloroquine resistant
geometrically pmcid and then the plasma
phosphorus multi-drug resistance gene
one
and pfcrt is on chromosome seven of the
maximum phosphorus and then pfmdr1 is
commercial five
and they have indicators to show and
resistance in chloroplane and also
atomic
and because of our presentation our
focus on pfcrt you could see the common
mutations
and which have been listed mutation at
position 76
72 74 350 and so on
and which 10 spells they need to further
understand
the effects of these mutations and
continually evolve in one step
and on the structure and function of
these genes and one won't be able to
study the
mutations on the structure and function
of these things it will
innovatively help us understand the
mechanism of of resistance
and also influence the identification of
novel compounds
that could circumvent the resistance
caused by astonishing and chloroquine
and now as i think mohit has already
spoken to this already so i'll just be
brief about this
now access of antmalia drugs into their
targets
and by target i mean um where the drugs
and uh yes in quotes are getting too
it's very important for the action and
so
intracellular targets include the
digestive vacuum
the cytosol microchondr apicoplast
or the parasite membrane intracellular
distribution relies
mainly on solubility potential to
permeate cell membranes and the binding
affinity to transporters
that regulate drug trafficking through
interstellar compartments now
eukaryotic cells um evade xenobiotics
and xenobiotics i mean foreign compounds
or all the drugs
by their toxicity by um trafficking them
into their digestive vacuum
and so this is the laser tobacco which
is in brown
and no gray sorry
for feather possession or or they expel
them extras extracellularly
yeah now plasmodium does this using um
two types of transporters which i've
already mentioned before which is the
p glycoprotein and liter transporters
which um
of course pfmdr-1 is included and the
drag metabolic transporter system which
is the pfcrt
now um when we look at the um
the way chloroquine works in terms of um
um
in plasmodium phosphorum and chloroquine
are commits in the food vacuum the
parasite and this accommodation may
involve
an ion trapping right and
the major action of proclaim is to
inhibit the formation of himalayan
as already mentioned from the hymn
released by the
digestion of hemoglobin now the free
hymn then lyses membranes
and leads to parasite death now clerical
resistance is due to the decreased
accumulation of
cloaking in the food vacuum and as i've
mentioned before
pfcrt and pfmdr1 have been implicated in
resistance but they the exact
um role the exact mechanism of action in
this regard is
not fully known right
next slide please
so i study focus therefore
now is to map known um mutations like
i've mentioned before the mutations that
um versus 76 72 and so forth
and then unknown mutations it means that
we'll have to and study their
populations and
come and see if there are study
populations in ghana and in africa
and see if there are actually unknown
mutations too
and then they are going to map those
mutations to the pfcr to structure so
it's latest function
and possible mechanism of action and
then also to identify
okay um
so here and my colleague and beta would
want to continue with this
thank you hello everybody
um good afternoon my name is rita yfree
bhatti and i'm currently um
a bioinformatics student at sherwood
university pursuing
phd and so i'll be just going through
the protocol that we proposed so
basically our project
actually span across everything that we
have done
and in this um this study
or this project
um so um spanning across genomics
to structure and whatever we are doing
now
so for our proposed and protocol we
aimed at identifying some mutations and
through the use of um looking at
mutability looking at multiple sequence
alignments
and other important tools that
we have learnt in this um course
and then after identifying known and
unknown mutation of this gene
we also ask the question that are they
structures or protein structures
available because
we actually want to see if we can
predict some of the mechanism of
resistance and
that this gene and uses so
if our answer to are these structures
available is yes
then now we go into the databases as the
templates have said
to retrieve those um and see this those
structures
however if our answer is no for
structural availability
then we go on to use um important
approach
and which have been widely used in the
area of structure
structures and availability which is
homology modeling
and our approach is to use the modula to
to do this however we also have
an issue with um protein structures that
some of them come with missing residues
so if we identified um a structure with
missing residues then it is very
important for us to model
that side so we also come in a point of
also after retrieving the available
structures
checking if there are misting residues
and also using the same approach as
homology modelling
to model those those approaches
so our question our next question we
asked ourselves after that
is that um are these mutation mutations
that we have identified
important are they located at um
important domains are they located at
the active site and other properties
so for that we will make good use of
all the visualization tools which have
been mentioned in the
in our course using like chimera using
like
um primo to identify if this mutation
that we have we identified mapped on the
structure
actually occurs at functionally
important regions
so from there we will also try and also
model the mutated mutant residues that
we identified
so from here we have um pdb of
mutated residue mutated and proteins
and also the wild type so with this
um results our first thing that we want
to ask ourselves is that
is there any effect of mutation on
structural flexibility or
stability and for that we would
look at the apple system first if i'm
talking about apple system i'm talking
about
a system with no ligand or no a compound
so for that we have the ecosystems which
is the wild type and also the mutants
that we will be um looking at our next
thing we can also do is to also
um do analysis with the um
drug that we have of interest which is
called queen in the presence of cochlea
so we want to see if there's some
effects
on them on the drug um in respect to
this
so from there our approach is to also do
docking so for us to get a structure
with
um croquin in in in complex we need to
do
docking and we make good use of some of
the available tools which
i think dr moritz will say more about it
and also make good use of like autodub
finer in autodog and other tools
so even as and the samurai has already
introduced so to in order to
for us to further evaluate our dynamics
and in a mimic cell environment we would
do um md simulations
which will make good use of gromacs and
also
other important tools for analysis and
for our analysis we would make good use
of looking at
and the roots mean square deviation how
flexible the residues are
and the compactness of the structure
during the dynamics
and hydrobonding hydrogen bonding
formation and also breakage
so another aspect that we are asking
ourselves is that
with all this um mechanism that we're
identifying
can need to be a basis to um
discovering a new or involved drug which
works better we can work better on this
mutated and genes so our next question
was to
do um better screening of approved drugs
and also natural drug
databases and in order to identify novel
compounds and
for this our approach will be
having all the pdb structures for the
mutations
and also the wild type which will be
like our control
so it will go through the same process
which we will do
docking of all these compounds to both
the mutant and the wild type
and from there we will now and those
compounds that
um actually give us much better energy
and also can have an effect on the wild
type and also the mutants that's what
we'll prioritize
and that will subject it into md's which
we'd want to further evaluate
whatever dynamics we are seeing so it
also go through the same approaches
looking at
the flexibility of residue hydrogen
bonding interaction
and um with this novel compounds which
is also very good that we can also com
compare it to their croquin and see and
the differences
and if we can get another better um
approach or another better compound
which is more than the cochlea
so from there i think the baseline of
our research is not just to end
just to identify um compounds using in
silico
but then we also make good use of
collaborations to
do in vitro assays for further
validation
of our compounds this has widely been
used
so the approach of this is very
important because i'm using this we'll
be able to
cut off costs and also
make good use of our time so and we make
good use of the in vitro acids to
further evaluate
um the compounds that we will be
identifying
and then we place the next slide
so we we we started something um
we started something before um this
presentation
so what we did was that we tried to
identify our structures if
indeed our structures are available
because that is the basis of our
analysis
so for us we were fortunate that we got
a structure for
um pfcrt and then
when looking evaluating their structures
we realize that there are some missing
residues
and detail please can you nest light
please
thank you so we realized that there are
some missing residues which you can see
over here and also appears in the
sequences
so it was very good for us to try and
model that side
so that we can now subject it into md so
we try other um
service and also make good use of modula
to see if we can model
this region and i think that is what we
have here
and then we also try just a primary
results to see what's what's
what we can do with this data we also
try to identify
um all the known mutation mutation that
has been known to cause resistance
and also map them to structure and as
you can see the
structure here these are the mutations
that are known to cause
um resistance and if you look at down
here so it's not visible but
this domain down here is very important
for
m the parasites so
this actually is um um
a foundation for whatever what we want
to do and i think this
section will give us more insight into
all that we want to do thank you
okay thank you rita and nigel mohite i
think we can pass it
back to you yeah thank you
and thank you nigel and
hello can you hear me hello hello
okay yeah let me share my screen again
so uh the structural characterization
and thank you for giving us the overview
so now we can talk more about maybe
the structural analysis that we could do
on top of the information that we have
already
so to learn to talk about the structural
analysis
and what all one can do
once one has the model so
before having a model uh you
you may have the sequence right so you
start from a sequence
and from the sequence you start looking
at
what are what are the available
structures for that sequence
says uh are there or not so when you are
looking at the available structures
uh you are searching through the blast
p program so there is in
blast so maybe i can show you all
so when i go to blast p
which is the protein sequence blast
so when you have a sequence and you
don't know whether there are any
structures available for the sequence or
not
so maybe you can start from this place
uh
very basic so here you have to paste uh
the sequence of your
interest the sequence that you want to
model the protein of
uh and then here you change it to
protein data
so once you do that you do the blast
then it's pretty simple
place the sequence here and then change
the data set here database here and then
do glass
so once you do that the sequence that of
that is of your interest
will searched against the protein
databank
so there you will find the closest
homologs that are out there
another option another few options are
there for modeling
and i would want to tell you all about
that those
so swiss model
so swiss model uh is again another
web server where you can model your
proteins
and also there is a docking uh
platform available says doc so here you
have to paste your sequence
and then you have to name the title and
then you put your project and then you
can search for templates which means
that
what are the closest uh templates
available for you to model so templates
are those
which are uh which are aligned
with your sequence though templates are
those that are the closest
uh sequence aligned to your sequence of
interest
so this is again maybe i also have like
maybe a login here
so if i log in i can show you the
analysis
and maybe one case study so what we are
looking at
is pfcrt and today i showed you that
uh so i have the
pscrt so today i showed you
that um that the
model for pfc ert uh
could be built
through these many different templates
so we have the
cryo-em structure and then we have
different structures that are
uh that shows a lower homology
but are transporter structures
so sometimes this information might not
be enough
so one of the disadvantages uh
from a structural biology perspective is
uh
for using a crime structure is that as
rita like rightly said that many parts
are missing
so some of the side chain information
which is very important to learn when
you're looking at mutation especially
so when you're looking at mutations
you're expecting the side chain
because the backbone is going to be the
same and then the side chains that vary
from amino acid to amino acids
have to be you know traced so one of the
problems with a
higher resolution or sorry lower
resolution structure or
maybe cryovm structure is that that you
don't get
that much amount of resolution so maybe
if there is a crystal structure
that would give you a better uh
understanding so here you will see the
template
so all the templates that are out there
that it found
so this uh this uh server uses
um hhp bits uh which is a which is an
algorithm to do this
so you can use that separately as well
and then it gives you different kind of
scoring
to choose the template so you can choose
here what kind of
uh based on the score and based on the
based on the different scales so
sometimes when you are modeling and this
is very important
so once you are modeling in then
basically what we do is that we model
one uh chain so one chain is what
is a monomer so proteins can uh
can be present in different uh
multimetric states
so they can be monomer they can be dimer
they can be trimers they can be exam or
maybe multimers so this oligostate
state and this
modeling of our oligostate is important
in those
examples when the protein is functional
in a trimeric or a monomeric or dimeric
state
uh not in monomeric but dimeric are
higher merge where the
there are there so in this model this
option is there to do this
but otherwise you can do it uh in using
the
crystal structure so we will just
quickly go also back to the
protein data bank so before we go into
the protein data bank let's click here
and see this what residue is this and
maybe we can go from here
so structure and drug resistance of the
plasmodium falciparum transporter pfcrt
is published in nature and this is a
chloroquine resistant transporter
with uh b and c chains and this is
from pdb and here you have the structure
so you can visualize the structure in
three dimension
and there is something bound here as
well if you can see that
i'll zoom in
so what is the ligand here you can see
the ligand so you have a ligand here
already and you have
active site that you can target so
this is cholesterol that is bound here
and pl ip is a intraphore
plip interaction so you can see the
interaction what kind of interaction it
is making
so there are hydrophobic interactions
and there is also a salt bridge
that is forming between the residue of
the protein
and the ligand so this sort of
information you can
i see right here and this is about the
template
so the template is the crystal or the
cryovm structure which is the
experimental structure
so here uh learning about the experiment
structure
more you can simply search this
if you search 6ukj
the first link that is going to come up
is the rcsv
so the rcsv is a protein data bank where
all the protein structures are deposited
that are experimentally derived so
here you will find this entry and you
can totally download this file from here
you can also download just a sequence
file and you can also download structure
three-dimensional file that you will
just see
uh by by using this menu so here it is
classified as a membrane protein
organism expression
vector about the experiment that was
done to
express this protein and
and then the technique here you will see
here you will see the molecular weight
and how many atoms are there
how many residues are there here model
means that
it's a modeling through uh software
which is to model the residues
within the electro electromagnetic sorry
uh the
the mesh of uh electrons that we get
from the experiment
so this is not like other modeling that
we are doing so anyways uh we have here
different
types of tabs that you can go and look
into and a lot of information you will
find here
and as i was telling you about the
biological assembly asymmetric unit is
in the crystal structure you can read
about the paper that
that got uh published along with this uh
this structure which kind of
a hundred percent describes the
structure in much more depth
uh so this is this is something that you
should do
so other than that this information you
can get the protein structure here
as well as the ligand uh residue
you can you can use that ligand for
another other studies as well
so this is the protein data bank and
you're free feel free to
you know kind of explore this and also
you can search by name of proteins by
name of
whatever you have in your mind about a
structural
aspect of our gene so here you can
search and
do that so going back to the
template uh here what we have seen in
model
is uh we have seen the templates now we
will see the model
and as rita was telling you that we will
be using
modeler and so there another uh way to
use modular is
mod uh mod web which is the
which is the uh
which is the server version of the of
the tool
so here in the server version again you
can just put the sequence here
and then you can name email address and
this
key if you have academic address
academy email address you will get this
key and that you will also be requiring
to do
the modeler so here in sally's lab
you will find different other tools also
that are helpful
to understand different aspects of
structure
structural biology or so it's a good lab
and they have generated a lot of great
tools so this is modulus
so in ucsf you will also have ucsf
chimera
which will be used for visualization so
as we are running out of time i will
just now
focus on maybe the structural analysis a
little bit
so let's go back uh to that
and let's open this structures
so before we do that i just wanted to
tell you uh
in quick uh slides that how the
structure is being modeled
so when you model a structure then you
can do what you can do
structural comparison so when you do
structural comparison which is
uh superimposition so what we do is that
you align your 3d structure into another
3d structure
like you might have heard about sequence
alignment where you use cluster
w or you use multiple sequence alignment
tools
to uh you know align two sequences
similarly you can align
structures as well so that there are
different algorithms that have been used
for this
so not going into those details right
now but to tell you
more about that when you align
structures then you get
the result of alignment as you know
the difference between the results in
alignment as
uh rms d uh root mean square deviation
so here you can see rmsd so this root
mean square deviation means how those
two structures differs differ
from each other and this uh this value
is usually denoted
in um angstrom it's a very small scale
so it's 1 to the power -10
so you're looking at very smaller state
of molecules
these small molecules and then you are
looking at these variations as well
between two molecules
in a strong so these are values in
angstrom
and this tells you about that that once
you have a structure and then you want
to
see whether how close this structure is
with another structure
that's quite possible so you can do this
in pymol
you can do this in uh chimera uh there
is a matchmaker
tool that is there in chimera which you
can use and then
uh once you have the model so here on
the right panel
uh you can see that there are some plots
and uh started
graph graphs are there so
while modeling uh what we consider is
that
we consider some of the matrices that
are
that defines the quality so those
matrices are important to evaluate
so uh for membrane protein there is
like this upper plot has q mean uh
membrane analysis
uh so pseudo energy is also being
calculated
for the transmembrane structures and
then the
graph shows the per residue local
quality
so these are the things that you might
want to consider when you're looking at
the model
and then one of the biggest takeaway
point that i would
want to tell you that is that once you
derive a model once you obtain a model
from the
from the tool like modular space model
or something like that
then the next step would be the better
step would be to do a energy
minimization
which can be uh through uh molecular
dynamic stimulation
so the energy minimization algorithm
what it does is that it
and minimizes the overall energy of the
molecule to a
global uh local uh lower state
and that global local state a lower at
lower energy
these molecules are more stable and that
actually kind of resembles what is there
inside
the organism so it kind of resembles
more closer to the
real real protein structure so however i
mean uh to
there are different scores that you can
calculate uh through ramachandran plot
so here you can see the psi and phi
angles that are plotted
in this graph and that tells you about
the outliers that tells you about the
quality of the models that how the side
chains are
modeled uh how good they have been
modeled
so in this binding site you have 10
transmembrane
transporter helices so the overall
structure you can see
this cartoon and the
the face which is towards uh uh so
vacuolar face
and then then these are the uh then you
can see these
pdb id identifiers so these are the
structural
uh identifiers and you can go into those
sites and look into those as well
now uh when modelling the pscrt and you
just saw that uh
the trita showed the the size the
binding and the
and the structures that we have created
with modeler
so uh going into the experiment i mean
it's important to understand so what cdp
is
what did you look at looked at you
looked at a prote
uh pdb pdb database and then you
looked into the structure so what are
what are these structures
so let me now maybe
show you that in three dimension so i'll
stop
sharing from this account and i'll move
to some uh another account
for sharing uh that so
let me try from there so elia can you
make
my other account uh also so it's dr
mohit alsumdar can you make that cohort
as well
it's called don't you thank you
so now let me
share this screen
so what we are trying to do now is to
we are trying to visualize these
proteins
by their structures so what we are going
to do
is open the protein data bank
using pymol so if you guys know pi
mall then it's great if you don't
then it's okay i will tell you in very
um
in concise but we can do that later as
well so we have some tutorials that we
can forward to you
to learn about this uh structural
visualization tool called pymol and
also chimera and you can do it by
yourself also this is very popular tool
so what we are looking at here is the
is the cryovm structure which uh also
uh showed
by vita and then maybe we can also look
at the model structures
so here we have the
model structures
right so what we can see here
is the uh all the
residue is right so here in the s if i
put the f button we'll see the sequence
so you can see the entire sequence here
and you can
identify the residues that cause like
that some mutation
that that is there so this mutation
uh k to p now let's look at with
uh look at uh with the help of uh
other visualization ways so i'll hide
every side
everything and then show cartoon
so we have this now cartoon view now you
can see this
into like the way it is
folded in helices
and loops and then
we have different settings that we can
use
to see these helices
into maybe a cylindrical form
so now we have the cylindrical helices
now what we want to see is those
active sides and
what we can do is that because it's a
model and we don't have the
crystal structure so we also have the
crystal structure
oh sorry like crying structure so now we
have loaded two molecules in one
so you can see in one in one
we have two molecules so how you can
compare these two molecules because they
are
apart right in a three-dimensional space
they are
away from each other so what we do is
that we align
so what we will do is that we will align
this like easy way to do this like we
can align like this
so now they are aligned so
you can see that
so this is the full structure like
everything so cartoon now you can see
that these
two have aligned and there is this
additional domain
that is there present in uh
in the pfcrt and these are the
transmembrane helices
so now you have aligned
now as i was telling you that you can
know about the rmsd so there is this
uh there are two panels that opens when
you open buy mall
so this second panel uh if i
show you the log here will show you the
rmsd
so this rms is 2.369 and strong
right so that's how you can compare two
structures in pi mall
and similarly it's very simple to do in
chimera as well
so now i mean we would want to do some
structural analysis so one has
the ligand another one does not have the
ligand so it also has other chain
so maybe we can also see this
by display by
chain identifier so we have chain a
chain h chain h is this side
and then chain l so these two molecules
h
and l so we if we hide
no wait we also have the
ligand so we were finding the ligand
excuse me
one doubt uh will you please tell me
again how you have brought two
structures
in one one screen i just missed it
so let me redo it from the beginning
i'll just close this
so i have downloaded the structure so
let me
again do that also
so i will show you from the beginning so
that there is no confusion
i'm sorry
so 6k
i searched this right and then i got to
here and by the way i have the models
okay
uh downloaded and created so that was
before
so i just downloaded this one so you you
have one part that
is clear that part is clear means
we do have some two structures we are
opening it together
but only how you have opened it we just
missed it
so i just did like this i opened it here
uh now this again panel i opened another
one and you can like
that way open several structures so you
can open 100 structures at one time and
do the analysis
so now going back to the problem at hand
so we have the structure
loaded now i have also the models that
we have created
so this is another model that is there
and i want to put in this model
uh where the active site is so how do we
know in the model where the active site
is for our docking studies
because we are going to use the model
right so
now we will look at the sequence so we
looked at the sequence
and this is where the module
is okay now we have to do the alignment
right
to see how they are
aligned to molecule pfcrt now they are
together right
now we'll remove this because that shows
the residues and now this is the
molecule
now what i did before if you like two
molecules at a time it will be in two
different windows right
no i mean we opened it we opened it one
window why would it be in two windows
we have it in one place in one one one
place
so here it's going to populate in this
panel if you see
now you have two structures you can
visualize one at a time or you can
visualize select one or select none
so here i can load more and more
structure
so it does not matter
you are just opening it again
yeah i'm loading other structures into
the same panel
and here we have multiple structures
that we want to
visualize anyways going back to the
study and we are running out of time
sorry we can maybe figure this out later
because it's a personal problem i guess
so this is
uh these are opened in one window and in
one window you have a panel
here on the right where you can load
multiple structures
and then you can analyze multiple
structures so it's kind of pretty simple
so uh now maybe we can show you again if
after the session or maybe sometimes
else
please reach out to us about that so uh
i will hide everything
and i will show you the cartoon and then
what i was trying to do is that i wanted
to see the
uh just a ligand right so
now the ligand is
here y01 now uh the ligand cannot be
in in this uh in this form because it's
a
it's a small molecule and it does not it
cannot attain like a
3d structure like this but it can be
seen as
sticks or lines so we'll do sticks
and then we will color it by uh
this sort of coloring scheme where you
can see
that the oxygen molecules and the carbon
molecules also
so here we have the crystal structure
sorry the
atom uh so the ligand and we
also have the two other molecules now
what we are trying to do is that what we
are trying to build a complex
of drug and the uh maybe the drug
binding site or whatever
with the receptor so what we are going
to do is
uh that we are just going to select this
and we are going to copy this
copy this object now this is an
additional copy that has been created
now i'll remove this now we have these
two molecules together
now this is our model and this is the
site and now i can also look into the
interaction
here so it's this uh a co-complex
model that you got just by superimposing
without talking so here uh what we will
do
similarly we have found a site and now
we will have to uh go to autodoc
and then define this site and then we
will do the simulation
but i think uh that maybe we can cover
in the next session
uh it's more about preparing the system
to be
to to become more ready for the
simulation
and now we will also look at the
mutation so let's look at the mutation
so loop mutation was at the 76th
position
so here at the 76th position i have
highlighted
and then when you click here and
you can see that it gets selected when i
click here it gets selected
so when it gets selected you can go to
the select
part because this is what it selected
object one is the ligand and these are
the different
uh the different uh molecules that i've
loaded so three structures i have loaded
and i was just doing analysis with one
structure what i did was
i took uh the the experimental structure
and i extracted the ligand from the
experimental structure and put it in
put it together and then i wanted to put
it together with the model
that's uh that's simply what i'm trying
to do and also now i wanted to look at
the mutation
so how this mutation is going to
influence the structure so this is the
mutation right here
uh so i will show it instead
show inspect so now it is green and
stick i can also change the color
to any color i like so maybe
pink because it's bright
okay got it so now we have the mutation
and
you can see this this binding site is
away from this
this cavity so this is a different
cavity where
the transport is happening which is the
chloroquine binding site
so uh maybe that's the hypothesis
now we want to validate it further and
uh we want to do the mutation so we want
to do
change uh this residue to thiamine
so k to t so how do we do that
uh threonine sorry yeah how do we do
that so we can do that
using uh primal only uh so here we will
go to two wizards and we will do
mutagenesis
so here in mutagenesis this panel comes
in
on the right no mutations
to mutation so we will do mutation
we will change it to your name
and this is the one i just selected
and then i'll apply
okay i have to select the residue
yeah now it is selected it has selected
the residue and now it is showing the
probability so here you will also see
some inference
so this is actually showing you the
probability of
this mutation here you will see the
probability
in in digits
15.8 percent probability uh for this
mutation to be like this
so uh i will do apply so it will change
the structure
so i'll do apply now it's t
so your k has changed to t so this is a
mutant structure
but how stable it is uh
is something that we don't know and
that's why i was telling you that the
next step
after this is molecular dynamic
stimulation
so uh now uh we have the structure
and we can totally save all of it now i
tell you how how do you do that
so you can do that by
selecting it so i'll select this entire
structure by just you know putting my
mouse around
right so it's got selected
and also i can do this uh without doing
this manually but i'm just showing you
uh you can do this by selecting the
entire chain
rather than selecting each and every
residue but i've selected all the
residues so they got
they are in the selection uh you know
menu and then i selected the
this uh ligand also just in case i need
a ligand
uh complex so the preferred one
would be here also so
we would get it by docking and then
we would be doing this maybe in the next
session so now
uh we have all the selection i will go
to file
and then i'll save molecule and then
i'll here
select the cscld select and now i'll
press ok
now this is our my molecule which is
which has the mutation mutant
uh k 76
to i'm sorry
so it's mutant k76 to t now it's safe
now my molecule is being saved like this
into one complex structure now which i
can use for another study
or the study so this is some
manipulation that you can do
and there are so many other things that
also you can do you can you should start
exploring
and then you should let us know about
uh doing this how do you do this uh more
and how do you do this in the context of
a project
so how we are in this uh in this
program uh we are working on the
different aspects of connecting this
data from
population studies then tracing it back
to the mutation
and then doing the structural analysis
and devising strategies
so in today's session as we have had a
lot of things covered
i think maybe we can uh shift the next
uh
to the next session where we describe
into the next test but
today what i wanted to tell you about
that to prepare a system and
make it available for your analysis is
very critical and very important
the more accurately we do it the better
results you will get
and this is based on my experience
because the mutations that we have
designed for the experiments and then
validating in them into a la into the
lab that costs a lot so each there you
are doing a lot of
you know in investing a lot of uh funds
to validate that so it's great when you
have the
right kind of results and then with that
information
you you're supposed to get good results
as well
so that is about the structural analysis
today now i would like to pass it on
uh maybe bishop to talk about the
research fellowship
and the projects
so yeah i don't know i don't know if
deepsea is here um
but uh maybe since we don't have a lot
of time
we can summarize this by speaking
briefly about
you know what have we planned for
taking these projects further so as you
can see from all of these
studies that have been shared today
the process from getting a project
idea to getting it
completed is not trivial
you have to have the capability to
collect data
process the data interpret what you have
found and make sure that it was done
correctly
up until the moment that you can
actually start thinking about you know
going into an independent direction so
what we have been thinking about a lot
in our experience
was getting you the right kinds of
resources that address
all of these uh issues that were
discussed
so let me briefly kind of tell you about
these resources so those of you that are
not
a part of a program yet can start
thinking about how to do that
and the first thing that i want to
introduce you to is the learn
omixlogic portal where all of these
things are kind of listed out
so our focus is on providing
assistance on biology as a data science
helping you acquire the skills
understanding the application of these
skills to specific projects and types of
data
and then letting you leverage this big
data
infrastructure to develop and conduct
independent research and so the logic of
this program
is to start with some small achievable
goals to get training
in these different methods of analysis
then
to perform replicate studies that have
been done by
researchers that know what they're doing
they're experts and what they are doing
and then once you understand the
methodology you can either decide to do
this
technically yourself and do some coding
and kind of understand
r and python or you can just kind of
replicate the logic using some of these
analysis tools that we have done now
today we've talked a lot about malaria
and
uh we have similar resources that are
dedicated to
oncology neuroscience and agriculture
where you can explore a variety of
projects courses and tracks that explain
similar topics in
application in each one of these we
we've provided some basic tools
that you can leverage for sequence
alignment
measure and understanding of rna-seq
experiments uh learn about evolution
and then also some tools for machine
learning and variant calling as well as
structural analysis
and of course we have some tutorials on
how to do certain things
in r and python and what's important is
that you can start with this
program for free so if you're on this
site
you can register for free and then gain
access to a lot of these tools
now two specific programs that i want to
mention that are coming up
one is we have learned today about
methods of simulation docking
and kind of translating these variants
to the structural
realm to understand what is really
happening happening
with these structures but we will also
explore
analysis of rna-seq data which are going
to be
useful to see what are some of the
translation issues that come out
as we study mrna transcription so how is
rna transcribed from dna how to measure
gene expression levels and also how to
understand
alternative splicing in the context of
bulk
and single cell rna-seq so there
we will have a full training program it
starts
april 16th which is tomorrow so all of
you are welcome to join our
free session the first session that we
will have for this program
and uh finally i want to also mention
a program called
drug discovery for those of you that are
interested in the intersection between
analysis of molecular structures
molecular dynamics
docking as well as data science
and how these skills are used in the
industry
we have this exciting program that will
be led
by pine biotech trainers including mohit
as well as some industry experts from
other companies so we do
welcome all of you to explore this
program
it is structured over the course of
several months because you can actually
focus on either chemo informatics and
artificial intelligence and drug design
or you can join sessions about machine
learning
or you can learn about different types
of omics data
and essentially design a project that
maybe leverages either
one or multiple aspects of these types
of analyses so
if you have any questions specifically
about this program i do recommend
reaching out to mohit mohit's email
is he
has been designing this program together
with his collaborators
at pharma toppers and faba academy
so this is a program for those of you
that enjoyed the session today and what
mohit was talking about
and you can learn a lot from him and
experts like him
in this upcoming program finally we do
have
a research fellowship that i want to
invite you
to explore the research fellowship is a
program for those of you that do not
really want to get a training program
but just want to focus
on doing your own research
so uh sorry newport i gave the link to
that
uh drug discovery program please take a
look there
maybe you can answer in the chat about
the program start
and all of those details so concerning
um
thank you so concerning the research
fellowship
uh the research fellowship is a program
to focus
on independent research and today what
you have seen the presentation by
nigel and
rita was kind of a view of what you
would do in this program so instead of
learning about the different tools
you would actually have the mentorship
and the guidance to kind of focus on a
research problem
that you can solve using various tools
uh that are either available
on our platforms or that you might want
to find that are more applicable to your
problem on hand
but you will have access to experts like
mohit
uh like harpreet who was here today uh
clinton
and others that could help support your
uh technical
um the side of the problem and also
guide you and then at the end you will
have access to some
expert feedback um and that expert
feedback comes from our collaborators
at the tower bioinformatics research
center at university of haifa
so here you can see a few examples of
projects that were done by some of the
people that have completed the research
fellowship
we also have some feedback
right here from people that have
completed and also
there are some description about some of
the tools and access to
a variety of things that you would gain
access to in this program
so if this is interesting to you i
recommend reaching out so you can either
uh learn more right here
you can get started i think there's an
option for three and six months
and also we have regular webinars
and thank you mohit there's a also a
pre-registration page where you can
learn a lot more about this
uh omixlogic biomedical drug discovery
program
so if you do have any questions thank
you mohit for pasting this link there's
a
an email for beeps at biswas she
is going to be helping you decide which
program is right for you
how to get registered how to get all the
details it's marketing at pine dot bio
so thank you everyone for joining today
uh hopefully you enjoyed this session uh
thank you
rita and nigel for presenting your
research project
uh thank you mohit and harpreet for
sharing from your background and also
mohit for the wonderful session on the
hands-on
molecular dynamics and all of that
and hopefully you will enjoy this
webinar enough to join our upcoming free
webinars
that we will have and we will post them
on our
social media so we do ask that you
join our linkedin group if you
enjoy these kinds of topics we have a
group on linkedin called omixlogic
if you want to interact with
professionals and experts in this field
and kind of see some job and internship
opportunities that would be the place to
go
we also have a group on facebook
where you can join by answering just a
few questions about yourself
and here you will also see this webinar
that is going on
so you you can see a lot of the
different things that we do we post
those videos right here
all right so um did you want to add
anything
uh to this i know yeah thank you
everyone i just wanted to thank everyone
[Music]
all right great so thanks for joining
and we will see you again next time
thank you everyone
you